foreign
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
So today we're going to talk about the
culture series by Ian M Banks this is
another large sprawling science fiction
Universe with many of its own unique and
interesting science fiction elements so
first of all there is a lot of books in
this series they all follow different
characters throughout the Universe and
different circumstances and situations
so in this series the culture is a
post-scarcity society kind of like the
one in Star Trek where humans and
humanoid aliens along with sentient
artificial intelligence and sentient
machines
live in harmony and what is basically a
Utopia now they don't really inhabit
planets they usually are on ships or
what they call orbitals which are
basically space stations you can also
consider the culture to be kind of a
post-human society because people aren't
afraid to upgrade themselves they have
all sorts of mental enhancements
physical enhancements sexual
enhancements they've been altered so
they can live for hundreds of years turn
off pain at will they can induce the
effects of psychoactive drugs at will
and essentially have a psychedelic trip
whenever they want instantaneously the
culture is a society that holds freedom
and individuality in high regard it's
essentially the best case scenario as
far as the future of humanity could go
and also similar to Star Trek the main
themes of this series center around the
moral and ethical dilemmas that the
culture encounters when dealing with
other civilizations and other societies
throughout this series
the culture is led by Minds the minds
are the most intelligent beings
biological or otherwise in the culture
now essentially a mind acts as the
center of a ship or a space habitat it
has the Computing capability to run the
entire space station or ship some
planets actually even have mines they're
so powerful Computing wise because
they're actually four-dimensional
entities and much of their computing
power comes from the fact that they
exist partially in hyperspace and can
calculate at essentially light speed so
I mentioned that there were other
civilizations in this story now the
culture is considered to be a high level
involved
civilization also called an optimey
civilization
so optimey civilizations like the
culture and others like it were often
the mentors and sometimes the rulers of
other civilizations
and then they're also the lower level
involved civilizations which had
achieved you know essentially
galaxy-wide contact with other societies
there were a small number of involved
civilizations more than Optimist
civilizations of course but certainly
not as many as there were Interstellar
civilizations that weren't sufficiently
influential there were potentially
thousands of these there are also what
are referred to as Elder civilizations
which are the civilizations that did
reach the level of advancement that
would allow for them to go Interstellar
but kind of retreated and didn't really
become involved in any Intergalactic
meddling
but finally
one of the most interesting and honestly
kind of terrifying types of
civilizations brought up in the Ian
Banks books is the hegemonizing Swarm
so the hegemonizing Swarm is a
civilization
but not really a civilization a
collection of entities that exist only
to convert the universe into more of
itself and it will do this until it has
used up all of the energy and matter in
the entire universe now this goes back
to a concept that's been talked about
and written about for years in his 1986
book engines of creation nanotechnology
Pioneer K Eric Drexler coins the term
gray Goo now gray goo is a hypothetical
catastrophic scenario which involves
self-replicating machines typically
molecular nanotechnology which grows
beyond our ability to control it and in
order to continue replicating consumes
all of the biomass on Earth because all
it knows how to do its main function is
to build more and more of itself so in
his culture series Ian Banks adopts the
term gray goo to describe the
hegeminizing Swarm type civilization
now it wasn't just these types of
self-replicating machine-based societies
that were referred to as the geminizing
Swarms but it could also be any type of
society that was singularly focused on
conquest and control of other worlds in
fact one of the central dilemmas that
the culture encounters actually involves
them Towing the balance when it comes to
intervening with other worlds and other
civilizations the balance between being
helpful and potentially becoming a
hegeminizing swarm themselves something
that just keeps growing and keeps making
more things into the same thing that it
is
so there's the Dilemma of can the
culture become the very thing that it
itself fears the most and of course the
culture fears this
what civilization would actually desire
to become the thing that eats the
universe the geminizing Swarm is one of
the most interesting Concepts that gets
explored in this series when it comes to
a civilization that is only interested
in Endless expansion
the question of where is this all going
eventually has to be asked what I like
about this series is that the World
building is very rich it's very unique
it has its own flavor the first book
consider fliebus actually focuses on a
character who is a shapeshifter named
horza we also learn in this first book
that there is a war between the culture
and this race of aliens called the
adirins and we get to follow horiza
who gets caught up in all of this and he
just has a really interesting
adventurous throughout that book and I
highly recommend it to anyone that wants
to get started in the series don't even
worry about reading the rest of it just
read that first book and if you like it
definitely continue on if you want to
learn more about the universe and to
uncover more secrets and to understand
more about the goings-on with the
culture and their interactions with the
other civilizations in the galaxy
so the final thing that I like about
this series is the humor there were
times that I laughed out loud I think
Ian Banks has a great sense of humor and
I'd like to see humor in sci-fi books
because a lot of sci-fi books especially
ones that I tend to read are kind of
dark and Grim but this one includes
humor while also broaching on some
pretty interesting and deep topics and I
think it's a really nice balance
thanks for watching guys let me know if
you want to hear more about the culture
Universe make sure you like And
subscribe for more Quinn's ideas peace
out
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]